so uh barbara you're up you have a
question for us
yeah hi well first of all thanks for
having me i'm super excited i'm a huge
fan
thanks um so my question is i'm sorry
if it doesn't relate too much to the
topic but my question is
i've found a guy that i think is like my
dream man just everything about him is
perfect do you have any tips of how to
keep him for the long run
okay so he's your dream man why
um he's super ambitious he's
to me incredibly handsome um he
is just like a leader you know someone
who i know can lead me i feel super
comfortable
um just like whenever i'm around him i
have no issue like submitting to a guy
like this
okay good so and you've been together
for how long
um we're about to hit two years two
years and he's how old
he's 22. i'm also 22. oh you guys are
young
okay okay so what's the plan here so
what are you asking what's the
big ask here yeah i guess my ass is just
you know how do i move i know you said
like most
most at least guys you know don't think
about long-term stuff until they're in
the 30s and stuff is there any way that
i can make this
like is there any way to have this be
something successful in the future
even if we're both the same age and
super young got it yeah okay so
i i tell guys not to get into long-term
relationships
in their twenties because they're not
very good with women one and two
they really need to build a foundation
for their lives not get distracted by
some chick in a long-term
relationship so here you guys are at 22
i'm guessing he doesn't watch my stuff
but you do um i do
he i don't know if you watched your
stuff or not i think it's kind of my own
little
secret that i'm a little red pilled as a
woman you know it's something i keep to
myself but he seems
if he doesn't if he does watch his stuff
or if he doesn't he seems very naturally
outfit like his inclinations are very
masculine very like he doesn't i never
tried to [ __ ] test him or anything like
that because he seems very you know like
he wouldn't take that
well believe it or not you probably do
you should test them you just don't
women don't notice when they do it yeah
um like at 22 like what are you guys
doing you in school do you work like
what do you do right now um
we both graduated i'm still looking for
a job it's been a bit hard with the
pandemic
but he is working um the thing
i know you said that a lot of guys you
know they don't know how to handle women
yet
i think he's a little bit different in
that he's
he um he has a lot of other ladies like
going after him before
he got committed like i it was
definitely a bit of a struggle to get
him to commit because he just has so
many other women like going for him so i
was kind of shocked that he
decided to you know become more
exclusive with me
but why do you think he picked you um
at first i was clueless i was like yeah
why would he pick me because i think i'm
i'm decent looking but i'm not like i'm
not i'm not a victoria's secret model or
anything but
in his like in his dms which i found out
a lot later when we were finally
exclusive
there's literal models like sliding to
its dms and
all that stuff it's kind of scary you
know when you're dealing with a guy of
that caliber
it kind of makes me a little nervous
well sometimes you got to share a high
value an alpha that's just the way the
world works right
yeah that's that would make me a little
scared not gonna lie
so you wanna know how to keep this guy
around it's pretty simple i mean when it
comes to men
i mean there's a lot of memes out there
that like boil it down too well if he
doesn't have a boner then put a sandwich
in his hand if he's got a bone rhythm
take care of that
sort of thing it's really just two
things um i mean there's a bit more to
it than just that but
women are always gonna be beauty objects
and and men like to be around
i mean if he's an alpha dude like like
strong virtuous masculine alpha dudes
want to be around
feminine women that are in their frame
that are compliant that are pleasant
you know that that [ __ ] tests them as
little as possible they don't bring
drama into their lives
um you know they do as they're told if
there's a boundary set then you
you know then you stay within the
boundaries um that's what guys like that
typically look for so i mean as long as
you keep doing that you manage your
beauty and your attraction
um you know i don't know maybe you guys
will be fine in the long run you guys
you know pop out a few babies and live
happily ever after i don't know
the chances that happen are pretty slim
so enjoy it while you're there
um you know maybe it goes for a while
maybe it doesn't yeah that's true thank
you i
yeah i want to come in john sorry man
no i think uh my only advice would be
like
be open and honest and talk to about
what his vision for the future is where
he's going
you know and don't get sucked into the
one-nightest thing
women fall for it too don't think that
they're the only person that's ever
going to be there they're the best you
could ever do and pull yourself into a
bad situation
but um yeah make sure you're you're kind
of at least going in the same direction
the other thing too is like um
men want men want women that are that
are on their purpose
that are that are a compliment to their
lives
right so if you want to make yourself
irreplaceable
so becky doesn't distract him
say that becky with big boobs is not
going to distract him i mean you know
he's going to look he's a man
yeah but he's definitely going to yeah
i've accepted that yeah but if you don't
want becky to distract him
then you've got to make yourself as
irreplaceable as possible
what skills are you going to bring to
the table that the other
you know 4 billion women on the planet
aren't willing to do that you're welcome
exactly yeah i'm trying my best to like
i think
i know i'm a pretty good cook and i love
you know making food for us and taking
care of him that way but i also just
i follow the red pill women group a
little bit and something that i took
from there that i really liked that they
say to be a soft place for him to land
you know like
all day he's out there like fighting the
world like trying to conquer his like
his own share of the world and
you know it can be tiring stuff so i
just try to be a nice place that he can
come for comfort
after you know a long day of working
hard of doing his stuff
i've never looked at the red pill um
subreddit so i don't really know what
the um
you know what the advice is but that
sounds pretty reasonable you know soft
place the land is
i mean they certainly don't want to come
home after a hard day's work and
be nagged and chirped all night
i can tell you from experience nobody
likes that [ __ ] yeah i try to make it as
pleasant as possible you know
to keep them around a little bit more
all right well
keep watching the stuff and let us know
if there's anything we can do in the
future all right
okay thank you so much for your help it
was great talking to you guys
all right see ya um
that's cute 22 year olds in love eh yeah
it's
hard it's a hard yeah
you